دير الزور بسوريا بينما تطالب
الحكومة السورية بخروج القوات
الامريكية من داخل اراضيها
وتعتبر وجودها غير شرعي. الرئيس
اليابان تقول ان بايدن يدعم مسعى
طوكيو للانضمام لعضوية مجلس
التابعة للموساد في ايران بل
تتعمد اسرائيل اثارة ايران
عليها عقوبات. اعلن وزير الدفاع
الامريكي ان نحو عشرين بلدا عرضت
على دراجة نارية. وبالتزامن مع
هذه الانباء قال الحرس الثوري
المخصب الروسي اكثر بكثير من
اعتماده على الغاز ورقة قوية
تزداد بين اثنتين من اقوى واعظم
الدول في العالم الصين وامريكا.
على حدودها الجنوبية لاقامة
مناطق امنة بعمق ثلاثين كيلو
الحياري ان تنظيمات ايرانية
خطيرة تستهدف الوطني في البلاد.
قيمة العملة الروسية. وقال
الرئيس الروسي ان الروسية يتحمل
في اي وقت. بوتين يقر بشبح ازمة
غذاء عالمية وينفي مسؤولية روسيا
عنها متهما الغرب بهذه الازمة.
بوتين التحول الى الروبل عزز
امدادات الطاقة الكهربائية في
دول باكملها. واشارت القناة
اوروبا متعددة الاطراف بهدف
رئيسي هو نزع السلاح ومراقبة
المتحدة. مفاوضات بشأن وضع
اوكرانيا التي ستنضم الى الاتحاد
انشاء قاعدة عسكرية في خرسون.
زالينسكي مستعدون لتبادل الاسرى
الروسية. بينما اعلن اوستن عن
اجتماع لاربعين بشأن اوكرانيا
الحدود الشمالية الشرقية للمملكة
الاردنية الهاشمية. حدة التوترات
مشيرا الى ان القوات المسلحة
تواجه حاليا حرب مخدرات على
تعطي رأيها. الخطة الايطالية
تتكون من اربع نقاط. وقف اطلاق
البلاد. اكد مدير الاعلام
العسكري الاردني العقيد مصطفى
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ان انقرة
ستشن قريبا عمليات عسكرية جديدة
ايطالية للسلام مع اوكرانيا.
وعندما تنتهي من دراستها سوف
الفين واحد عشر. وظهر كيم دون اي
قناع للوجه اثناء حمله نعش هيون
الهادئ تضم ثلاث عشرة دولة بينها
الولايات المتحدة واليابان ولكن
اثنين وستين عاما في شمال شرق
البلاد في اولى ايام الغزو
على عناصرها بينما اكد الرئيس
الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي ان الثأر
اعلام ايرانية وجود علاقة بين
عملية الاغتيال وتفكيك الخلية
ضربة العقوبات الغربية بشكل جيد
على الرغم من كل الصعوبات.
تقديم مساعدات امنية جديدة
لاوكرانيا لمواجهة القوات
وقال بايدن ان الصينيين يلعبون
بالنار الان من خلال تحليق
يغلبه البكاء وهو يشيع قائدا لعب
دورا رئيسيا في اعداده ليكون
الزعيم الكوري خلال جنازة هيونج
شولهاي الجيش الشعبي الكوري وكاد
طائراتهم قريبا من الجزيرة فضلا
عن جميع المناورات العسكرية التي
ويحذر الخبراء من ان اغلاق صنبور
اليورانيوم من روسيا يهدد بتقويض
الايطالية لكن هل تكون ايطاليا
الوسيطة لحل الازمة الاوكرانية?
الزعيم القادم للبلاد قبل وفاة
والده جونج ال في اواخر عام
الروسي. روسيا لم تكن لتقدر على
شن حرب على اوكرانيا لو فرضت
الجندي الروسي ذي الواحد
والعشرين عاما والذي اتهم
بارتكاب جريمة حرب في اوكران بعد
ان قتل مدنيا يبلغ من العمر
لدم العقيد سيكون في متناول اليد
بالتأكيد في حين رجحت وسائل
الجيش وصاحب الجثمان الى مثواه
الاخير وتقدم الصفوف المشيعة
ووضع التراب بيده في قبر معلمه.
وبحسب ما تظهر المشاهد فقد تأثر
يفارق معلمه كم الذي لطالما
تحدثنا عن قساوة قلبه ولكن اليوم
واردوغان يبدأ عمليات جديدة على
حدود الجنوبية الاردن تتهم ايران
تعلن القبض على شبكة تجسسية
اسرائيلية. فما الذي يجري في
جندي روسي. فهل ترد موسكو على
ذلك؟ زيلنسكي يعود للظهور على
ايران يا ترى للمرة الاولى محكمة
اوكرانية تحكم بالسجن المؤبد على
احباط محاولة تهريب كمية كبيرة
من المخدرات من الدخول الى
مترا لمكافحة التهديدات
الارهابية من هذه المناطق. بعد
الامن الدولي. قافلة عسكرية
امريكية ضخمة تدخل من العراق الى
بشأن شبه جزيرة القرم والدومباس
ابرام اتفاقية سلام وامن في
ورقة اليورانيوم. قالت قناة
الالماني يتحدثون كثيرا في
منتصف الشهر المقبل. ذكرت وكالة
الاعلام الروسية ان موسكو تدرس
من دون الصين. لن اقابل اي روسي
سوى بوتين وساقابله فقط لانهاء
الاثنين من طوكيو اطلاق اقتصادية
جديدة في منطقة اسيا والمحيط
الحرب في اوكرانيا. في خطوة
جريئة قضت محكمة اوكرانية بسجن
الاوروبي وليس حلف شمال الاطلسي.
اتفاقية ثنائية اوكرانيا وروسيا
كيم? مبادرة ايطالية لحل الازمة
الاوكرانية. وروسيا ترد
فكيف ستنتهي هذه القضية. حزن
المجنون. بخطوات بطيئة وحزينة.
بالفشل بحسب ما نقلت عنه وكالة
شينخو الرسمية للانباء. واضافت
ان الامر الخطير خصوصا هو
المتحدة تلعب بورقة تايوان وورقة
وسواء اكان بقصد ام بغير قصد لقد
بدأ صراع العمالقة في العالم
هكذا قالها بايدن. اي تدخل صيني
في تايوان لن نصمت عليه وسنتدخل
الايراني انه فكك خلية على صلة
باسرائيل وجهاز الموساد والقى
للحرب. الاحداث والتطورات. اعلن
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
العقيد صياد خداي في طهران
لتعرضه لاطلاق نار من مسلحين كان
حذر المتحدث باسم وزارة الخارجية
الصينية الولايات المتحدة بسبب
في العلاقات الامريكية الصينية.
من جانبها اعتبرت الصين ان
نرى الدموع في عينيه ليثبت لنا
عكس ذلك. حيث حمل كيم نعش قائد
بحر الصين الجنوبي لاحداث فوضى
في المنطقة. بايدن هدد الصين
اوروبا عن حظر النفط والغاز
الروسي. ولكن يتم عن غير قصد او
تمتلكها موسكو بجانب النفط
والغاز. فهل يتم استخدامها?
الاستراتيجية الدبلوماسية
الامريكية في اسيا محكوم عليها
الالمانية الى ان الاتحاد
الاوروبي يعتمد على اليورانيوم
يجرونها. بايدن لا يريد جعل
تايوان اوكرانيا ثانية فهل
اغتيال جديد في طهران. اعلن
الحرس الثوري الايراني مقتل
عمد التزام الصمت بشأن
اليورانيوم المخصب من روسيا.
تصريحاتها الاخيرة عن تايوان
ووصفها بالخاطئة وبانها قد تؤثر
صراع العمالقة. العجوز الامريكي
بايدن يهدد اصحاب العيون الضيقة
ويدعوهم لحرب مفتوحة ان هم
تجرأوا على غزو تايوان خرج بايدن
يستطيع منع اصحاب العيون الضيقة
من تنفيذ اجتياحهم المتوقع? ترد
نتعجب انا نقول ذلك. مبادرة
ايطالية. روسيا تعلن تسلمها خطة
في ظل تفشي فيروس كورونا ببلاده.
يا لوفاء هذا المجنون. وهنا
وما من رد ايراني على ذلك بينما
تعزز امريكا قواتها في سوريا.
حتى من ورقة الغاز نفسها. في وضح
النهار اغتيال ايراني وطهران
الشاشة مجددا وبوتين يعلن خروج
اقتصاده من الازمة بنجاح.
واشنطن بذلك تحديها لبكين بين
الصين وامريكا صراع العمالقة
ام ان البيت الابيض سيصرح ويقول
انها مجرد زلة لسان؟ وهل اعلنت
بالايجاب. ورقة ضغط جديدة تضعها
روسيا للضغط على اوروبا وهي اقوى
الاسلحة ومنع نشوب نزاعات. ليس
هناك تفاصيل دقيقة عن المبادرة
النار في اوكرانيا ونزع الاسلحة
على الجبهة تحت اشراف الامم
وصرح بجاهزية امريكا للدفاع عن
تايوان عسكريا بوجه اي هجوم صيني
وانها ستفعل ما يلزم لمنع تغيير
حالة الوضع الراهن من جانب واحد.
والدموع في عينيه ها هو المجنون.
آآ اقصد زعيم كوريا الشمالية.
نحن عسكريا. اسمعتم ام لا؟ اانت
متأكد يا بايدن من تصريحك هذا؟
هيمنة على العالم. لطالما رأينا
قساوة قلب المجنون ولكننا اليوم
فهل ينذر هذا التوتر بكارثة
عالمية
نرى الدموع في عينيه ليثبت لنا
عكس ذلك. فلماذا كل هذا الحزن يا